attorney general merrick garland finally
addressing the unprecedented fbi raid on
former president trump but
where president biden and fbi director
christopher wray
both men remaining very tight-lipped
as i'm sure you can appreciate that's
not something that i can talk about so
i'd refer you to the department
mr president mr president what do you
say to americans who think this is
terrible what do you say to americans
who think this is a politically
motivated search of mar-a-lago
president biden claims he's been in the
dark about the fbi raid among other
things but a new york times report from
april is surfacing it says that last
year joe biden told his inner circle he
believed donald trump was a threat to
democracy and should be prosecuted over
january 6th
right now biden's on vacation hanging
out with his son hunter though
here's what people don't like in the
country judge
we get that
you don't want to go out and just hold
press conferences in the middle of
investigations we understand that
but something this high profile and then
to go dark for 48 hours while
your department is leaking to the new
york times and leaking to the washington
post oh this this this this
we don't like that and that's why we
don't trust the process because it's not
clear to the public no you're right and
you know i was going to mention this
earlier the idea that you know we don't
talk when there's an investigation what
are you talking about the fbi is known
for leaking and leaking and leaking it's
what they do it's how they get their
word out so the juries are tainted that
kind of thing i mean i've seen it for 35
years uh but the sad part about all this
is that hunter biden gets to go on air
force one hunter biden the guy who got
the gun lied on the pistol application
and doing drugs doing everything else um
and you know paid a play all over the
world
unprepared to do any of the stuff he's
being paid for nobody raided his house
nobody raided his apartment nobody
followed him the same with hillary
clinton the same with sandy berger that
justice depends upon what party you
belong to in this country we see it over
and over again and that's why americans
are disgusted with the criminal justice
system whether it's hunter biden or or
donald trump you get the exact opposite
they keep saying you know nancy pelosi
says you know no one's above the law
but i'm starting to think that there are
people who are beneath the law
there are people who are not held to
what the law is but are under the law
the democrats have really changed they
used to say oh don't trust the
government you know the the
the fbi and cia had infiltrated the
anti-war movement the civil rights
movement they'd spied on muhammad ali
they'd spied on on the black panthers
pretty much spot on the tea party for
everybody they've spied on right
and now the democrats are saying hey
they got a warrant they can go into
anybody's house go into anyone's wife's
dressing room and and rifle around and
no one should see anything and it's all
fine and dandy how did you guys change
from being so you know libertarian and
anti-government just say hey let the
government do what it wants with me you
talking to me i am talking to you and
all your people harold all your people
you know what i mean by that
i uh i i
normally say i have a slightly different
opinion i have a very different opinion
you know it's true
um i know that secretary pompeo
and the former national security adviser
mr bolton are delighted that the justice
department uh and then our law
enforcement officials did the right
thing and didn't favor
uh evenly without fear and favor and
protected them god bless them and god
bless those agents who protected them
two um look i get hunter
hillary
uh bill clinton all of them i mean i i
get it but we i can't get around the the
facts that are here we can talk about if
you guys want to talk about with a
hundred by and hunter bucks was
investigated i think under donald trump
and i think he's still under
investigation why is he under
investigation for so long
that's not uncommon for people for years
first of all i have no clue same grand
jury
listen to the same things you guys
listen to that we have before it's a set
of facts here i hope that uh uh that we
all the facts come out and if the
president uh is remains innocent because
he's innocent now and he's proven
innocent uh i'll be the first to say on
this show that a lot of what you're
saying is probably well he's assumed
he's just assuming
i'm willing to do that some people have
got to be willing to say the president
had the warrant and he had the receipt
and he said he didn't it's not it's not
about that that's not it's not about the
warrant and you know what it's not about
the crime we're talking abuse i mean
they doctor warrants they lie in
warrants we've already proven that if i
had your argument i'd be doing the same
thing so
to the point we made it earlier in the a
block dana they have to have what
the the uh they they have to have like
what the the nuclear uh
codes they have to have smoking gun
evidence of like massive national
security secrets what if they just have
you know some letters some documents
what is merrick garland going to say
that well because of the silence then uh
the speculation has filled the void and
one of the pieces of speculation that
some are writing about including andy
mccarthy wrote about this yesterday and
um he said that maybe it's not about
records that the search warrant was
broad and that then what they were
really looking for was a fishing
expedition for something to deal with
january 6th they did go into every
single one so
if they do that then i guess merrick
garland has something else to say but i
think is i don't i understand
christopher ray saying well i refer you
to the guy that i report to the justice
department guy and then matt garland
says okay yeah i signed it what i can't
understand is the white house
maintaining that nobody at the white
house was informed and let's just say
that the white house said we are going
to have a clean break we don't want to
have any discussion with the justice
department whatsoever i think that's a
very irresponsible and a dereliction of
duty because even if you don't want to
have to deal with something that you
think is repugnant or ugly it is still
your responsibility to oversee the
executive branch and it's your
responsibility as the commander-in-chief
and the president of the united states
to be informed and to be able to weigh
in and to use your judgment that that is
why you were elected and i think that on
monday night in addition to merrick
garland issue in a statement the white
house council could have said
we were informed we did not tell the
president didn't tell the president i
got problems with that too but at least
then we would know that there was
somebody minding the store at the white
house i mean they were all over these
guys with the so-called whips on the
horses they wouldn't shut up about it
greg but now they can't talk about
anything the president doesn't know
anything those were reigns remember
right and now they were whips they have
a problem with language don't they jesse
yes
montage would you like to hear it i
would like to hear a montage is it a
raid or not let's listen
it wasn't a raid on his house no doors
were kicked down it's all legal it's all
lawful it's not a raid and i know donald
trump is saying that this is a raid but
that's a gross exaggeration we have to
be careful not to adopt
the term raid the only reason you'd have
an uh a search like this and let's be
polite and call it a search and not a
raid trump talks about a raid on his
home no man there was no raid on your
home
all right well what would you call it
when they come with guns and rifles
obviously one of those bachelorette
scavenger hunts right there just look at
one they had a little list
they were going through isn't that
amazing though when we do these montages
that it's so clear that there's one
script yeah there's absolutely one
script and it comes from somewhere i
don't know where it is maybe it's the
dnc who knows but it all comes down and
they all get okay this is what we're
going to say today and for once they're
interested in absolute definitions after
they refuse to define what a woman is
where they redefine recession where they
call black people white supremacists
like larry elder so they've been str
they stretched the language like brian
stelter and yoga pants and then they
come back and this there's a there's a
large event in which a large group of
armed people enter the house and they oh
it's just a search what's your problem
oh boy all right thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else